[Music]
such good
music love it what's up persia here i am
back with lily we were playing some epi
yesterday but today we're playing some
trover saves the universe
um this game is now officially out for
ps4 and pc
um also compatible with psvr which is
like the ultimate experience but today
we're just playing with the controller
yeah um you know so so we can interact
with you guys and see the chat and
not have goggles on but it's fine
because the game is still fantastic
either way um i know lily said she tried
this game
at e3 last year it was a lot of fun i
tried it with
vr and it was buckwild so i'm pretty
excited to do it with controller i've
never played it on controller so
i'm excited yeah it's gonna be great um
and i'm really excited i've been playing
this game as you may have noticed
the uh stream
is age restricted and that is with good
cause
because you can choose a censored
version or the uncensored version
and of course this is uh made by the
co-creators of rick and morty
so it's gonna have that crude humor and
um they definitely go all
in on the curse words which is why we
made 18 plus because we want to enjoy
the game oh what's the sense
in everything they just bleep out all
the curse words and
they curse a lot so it's like every
other word
is going to be like beep beep beep so 18
plus you guys we gave you the warning uh
we're gonna start a brand new game so
lily can check it out from the beginning
i'm a few stages in uh i've been
collecting all the
the uh power babies but we'll get into
that
in a little bit i love how it says this
game contains
naughty words yeah let's make sure it up
yes
um 18 and over is it well if you're
logged in already
then it will it won't ask you to
put your agent because it already knows
yes cute little doggies
oh they look like snowball
oh no oh let's turn this up
yes this is a vr game you guys but we
are playing just with the controller
today
just for the stream setups uh sake
and um but yeah it's versatile it's
still fun either way
oh as the change why don't you ever
rotate your chair samantha
all i ever asked this made me laugh
because my real name is samantha so when
i first started playing i was like
does this sink to like my my psn profile
i don't know
oh my gosh i love my pets yes yes
your lawyer here not looking good i'm
afraid because the dogs are yours and
because they seem to be powering this
monster
you may be liable call me end of message
message three sites to see
already what's going on here a little
bit
of message
[Music]
my dog all right
little cat scratcher says yep i'm buying
this game i'll be right back gotta go to
best buy good
choice i like really love this game
right now it's great
it's like the humor it's really funny it
breaks the fourth wall like all the time
also i hope we get to me we don't have
time to get into it right now you're
coming with me
oh we interrupt this program for
important breaking news
a giant big monster you heard that right
a mother
destroy the science center damn they
have the city stolen science equipment
microscopes beakers i'm talking about
flames things are really crazy right now
shit's all [__] up and this goddamn
big mom
has dogs that are plucked into his eyes
and they are powering him up
above any power level i've ever seen i
would watch the news
if it was like this all right back to
your regular schedule please you really
you're dogs
you have no idea how [__] things are
because of your two stupid dogs
hey you don't call those dogs you got it
yeah
this is a power baby you're going to be
seeing a lot of these throughout the
whole game i mean i really love them
i got them in my eyeballs you know in my
eye holes i mean
so just here look at this one that i
just pulled out of my eye and it'll come
to you just look at it and it'll come to
you
oh there it goes there it goes all right
listen you're gonna control me man
cause i'm tired okay you know how long
it took me to find you
i'm exhausted the blue light that's
shooting out of the ground that's called
the warp
node get me over to the warp node all
right okay so now listen
press r2
i just like love all these little
details in the game too like that's the
only time that can happen where you bump
into him like that
but the fact that it kicks off like that
is just hilarious like oops bumped into
me
i like how it it's kind of like this
place in my home world where i get
all crazy messed up but what do you do
about that
you're just a dirty chair orphian hey
i'm a
good sheriff
oh who it is i'm locking you here and
making a citizen's arrest
no do you not think i don't know who you
are
huh take your head yes or no
you're wrong i do know who you are
that's weird the audio is like not
straight on those dogs are in the eyes
of that big monster and it is
[__] everything up now because the
dogs
give them some kind of super powers so
we have you
to blame for this [__]
that we're going through right i can
only imagine do you feel sorry for what
yeah exactly do you feel bad for what
you've done no i don't my dogs are just
being cute they've gotten abducted
you have the two dogs
you know it's against the chair members
to walk
man i don't have time i got a
[__] sword
i aim for you
uncle
yeah you better turn that on yeah what a
dingle
oh should i go that way no i don't know
man i normally don't get like that but
but yeah so the other funny thing in
this game is like you know you can make
all these little decisions that so far i
don't
know how much or how heavily they affect
the story but you can make like
decisions like you can go kill that old
man if you want to
but like you don't have to oh my gosh
yeah yeah i got stuff
too for these guys
yeah so these are the bad guys what is
the game story
so basically your dogs got kidnapped by
this evil giant dude
puts him in his eyes and now he's gonna
take over the world because your dogs
are super powerful
and you basically have to go save the
universe now because your dogs got
kidnapped but everybody's blaming you
the dogs yeah i actually don't don't
know you're looking at the teleport
right now
[__] finally we're at the television
this is the telepod
so telepods are or how we get around
okay that's how we travel in the cosmos
they teleport us to where we'd like to
go so we're gonna use it to go to my
boss's office so i can drop your ass off
your stupid ass off
and get my space money and get the hell
out of here you know what i mean and go
live my life
go ahead and hit the button to uh
teleport us to my boss's office
leo says this question is for both but
your thoughts on pokemon sword and
shield direct i'm ready for it
i'm
they're always coming out with new
iterations and each one gets like better
and better
so i'm looking forward to it too in mint
condition
so i'll take my space money and be on my
way thank you very much
actually something i actually like the
bunnies
your job's not over yet come on you said
all i had to do was find the stupid
chair or be in
and bring them to you and then i get my
space money trevor shut the [__] up i
have the abstainers on the hollow dish
phone
[Music]
holy [__] that's what the abstainers
look like they look just like the
the guy who's got the dogs in his eyes
causing all this trouble shut the [__]
up trover no one needs to hear your
commentary about everything
the upstairs would like to talk with the
chair orpian it is true that we look
like glorcon
he was one of us we were four but he has
broken free
chair is it true you were the owner of
the dogs that power
glorcon yeah it's definitely the right
choir you should have
seen their apartment hey beck off what
we're saying is true
you are the owner of the dogs i told you
guys
we need to meet this chair orpian face
to face
you must come to our home world our
inner city wow whoa you're in
the inner sanctum void wow nobody's ever
been to the abstainer's inner sanctum
mama this is going to be quite a little
deluxe travel package
how does somebody even get to the
abstainer's inner sanctum you must find
the crystal of it
it is located in a place called slimy
world oh oh i know where schlimmy world
is all right okay all right trover
now i'm sure you can see better as to
why you i needed you to stick around
we need you to protect this chair orpian
you and the chair orpion are a team
you're partners now you're together
you're you're stuck with me
right [__] crystal in from slimy
world
so that you can meet the abstainers face
to face retrieve the crystal of it
you can plug it into the teleport it
will give you access to our inner
sanctum we must meet this
person it's of the utmost importance
okay all right we got it jesus
uh go ahead and hit the button on the
telepod there uh to teleport to
schliemmy
so did rick and morty help with this
game yes
co-creators of rick and morty did help
with this game which is why
um you know it's so awesome that guy's a
[__] [__]
man i didn't i didn't sign up for this
[__] you know and now the abstainer
justin roiland absolutely nails the
stammering and hesitation
of organic conversations yeah he does
that's what i really enjoy about this is
that it feels very
realistic in terms of like i can totally
see someone actually being like this in
dialogue in this situation
yeah i can see someone with eyes for
eyes
they make me uncomfortable you have
stainers
they do are we here we're here
we've made it oh my gosh who are you
hi we're at shilimi world look at me
oh boy all right who who is this guy
i told you i called her number i don't
know who i got
mr pop-up oh no not me
the [__] off there's a man named michael
and he built a house
on the bluff and and that's not zoned
for residential usage
it's zoned for public use and i'm very
upset about it
dude it's got nothing to do with us we
got our own [__] to deal with all right
you gotta help me out i can't do
anything this guy
michael he's a total [__] at least
he's treated me like
[__] good no way
no it's bad he thinks he's out
no he's back
[Music]
you're disgusting you're naked i'm
floating up here now you can't hit me up
here
you're disgusting [__] [__]
get out of here disgusting
[Music]
hold on i'm choking on something here
i'll be right back
jesus i hope whatever he's choking on
kills him
[Laughter]
oh oh gosh oh oh oh oh i killed him
no it's okay that's supposed to happen
oh really yeah oh someone's over there
they just killed me
you see the hearts on on your controller
when those go down to zero i die
and if you find any red power babies
those things will give me health
the more important thing is we focus on
finding the crystal
holy [__] how did you get that the
abstainers gave it to me like 50 years
ago
to hold on to you guys want it you guys
need this i want
people to have it yes if you need it
please well now
you have to do what i say where did that
crystal go
help you out you're gonna need a chair
upgrade because you can't even see over
this long chair upgrade upgrade here it
comes
[Music]
hey what the hell are you looking for a
spit all over the chair
i just
[Music]
do you see the house yes
use your boogie blinkster's house it's
way back there
you see it don't you see it to the right
that's michael's house that's the house
i need you to destroy right
all the way up there don't be stupid
don't be a jerk use the pop-up ability
often
without it you're screwed got it missing
a hard jump pops up
can't see where to go next pop up or
down i'll be back
soon now go get rid of that god
got it all right i heard get rid of the
house oh gosh
guys
so yeah on your journey you'll see like
if you go look over to the right a
little bit
there's like um oh where'd it go where's
like these little balls oh there it is
like they look like little gobstoppers
okay so you can destroy those and it'll
like give you a power baby or you can
just find the power babies floating
around oh check it out yeah we were
supposed to just get the
crystal of it oh we can just run through
it if you want but there's like a lot
um on the bigger stages there's usually
like 30 power babies
and then on the smaller ones nonsense
why can't
so the red one gives you health the
green ones you um
just got another green power baby more
health points yes you collect them so if
you hit the touch pad it'll show you how
many
you've collected so far so that's like
how many is in the world and then how
many that you have
up there
the abstainers are probably gonna i mean
they were mean on the holodeck
yesterday same oh okay so i guess go on
that line wait
oh yeah got it i've just been killing
him this entire time
he's like what the heck okay let's do
this i can go higher right
[Music]
all right this is what i'm talking about
man thank you
all right let's go guy yeah let's
proceed
[Music]
that's where it gets a little bit well
this is as far as we go
got ourselves a real oh [__] look look
above the gate
one of these things got a thumbs up on
it before they were all three
try popping up you know check it out up
there oh yeah
i see i see what you're looking at up
there three buttons
oh that's great i got it holy
that's insane it's an insane puzzle
i mean what the hell what oh okay so
it's like
you're doing all right jesus i don't
know
should we check online
online all right which one do you hit
oh my god this isn't fun this isn't a
good game
it's just a bunch of buttons it's like
i'm so close
[Music]
come back down screw
[Laughter]
am i supposed to actually talk to him i
don't even know anymore honestly i don't
know if you can actually finish this
puzzle
i've tried to finish it oh so i've just
been doing that for nothing okay
and then he's like you know what forget
this puzzle
so i actually don't know if you can why
do i even defeat it
why did i even try i should have just
thought about that
[Music]
oh can i hit it i think you might have
to go around for that one oh okay
i like i'm like yeah you know what i
totally if this puzzle is solvable
i'm like in the back of my mind part of
me is like it has to be solvable
you know we just give in because
trover's like come on
come down here oh my god
oh there's another power baby so the
ones that just float there you just
stare at him
and you press r2 and then he'll come to
you
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh they're not that hard to find yeah
i've always really
had trouble with like one or two the
green ones are super important to me
they are i've been gathering green ones
by dude
so they'll like float and yeah hey
excuse me how's it going my name's tony
i'm upgrade tony i got a real issue over
here if you guys wouldn't mind
just checking in with me upgrades hey
yeah what's the problem i got these
little ankle biters over here they're
trying to kill me it's giving me anxiety
okay
what do you want us to do i want you to
kill them
it's so much fun it's the funnest thing
you've ever seen i've always wanted to
there we go
sorry about that you guys yeah
i turned mine down a little bit because
my voice was like power baby upgrade
i don't know what power baby it's on a
different level frequency
i feel like i'm too loud all the time
yeah this is definitely an m rated game
not suitable for kids under 17.
i mean they have a censored version but
what's the fun in that yeah there's no
there's no point all right i heard
something something not really
crime is like google should we have
googled for that
uh maybe i mean maybe there's a way to
solve it and
we just got it come back
wow that was very fast you guys are here
i'm glad thank you bob jones i i fixed
the chat on my end and there was nothing
wrong on your own
so here's that awesome power baby oh
whoa
double jump and glide oh sweet double
jump yeah
it's so useful too it's so useful um
yeah okay cool
oh you eat each other you see the [__]
he's eating the other ones [__]
insane that's what they do
together isn't that crazy and all the
powers are now and combined into this
one power
baby um isn't that well ready to double
jump totally
totally awesome yep not crazy in the
slightest
so there's like a little pin off to the
side that has these little guys in it
too
but apparently those ones are like um
upgrade tony's
pets so like if you kill them he's like
you murder oh really
what's wrong with you why would you do
that and he's like you just told us to
kill these other little guys
over here oh we can't tell the
difference that's racist
and then he cries for like the rest of
the stage like he never goes back to
normal
i felt so bad i was like upgrade tony
should be a bit more specific you know
i'm going to kill everything in anything
in sight that involves
i saw a baby i swear
i like how you're telling me so that
your save doesn't go away in vain
like i know where they all are we've
already missed like five but it's fine
oh no don't tell me that now i'm like
oh i know we missed the one we met okay
well but that one was because you didn't
have the double jump yet so sometimes
you do have to go back to the beginning
and get
uh power babies again after you get new
abilities and stuff so
well too late now we're in it let's see
in it to win it i believed in you
i believed in you too get out of here
yeah you start to develop early on this
love-hate relationship with trover
with troves a little power baby
our baby
okay let's go here
i don't know if it's unlocked yet but on
the controller you can press in
r3 and it'll like go directly to him
oh yeah you know where he does yeah
but i have heard multiple times that the
vr version is definitely the
the top tier version of this game which
i definitely have no doubt i love vr
i think yeah is awesome but i think for
games where you kind of have to search
for stuff
i would like like to be on the
controller a little bit more
yeah i think the hardest part is the
voice it's hearing stuff yeah
i wonder why it's doing that when i had
my headphones plugged in like directly
to
yeah the controller it was a little bit
better how they're not gonna get very
far
i'm ready let's go yeah all the enemies
they say like such funny little lines
and quips too
get out of here get out of here like son
of a [__]
oh more oh
come on [__] let's go
yeah this game is definitely awesome i
really have
loved playing it so far it's really fun
i just like
i like the fighting aspect of it it's
fun and you unlock more
cool abilities a little bit later on you
as the chair orpian
get to like throw things so you get to
like fight with trover
while throwing things at the same time
and that's pretty that's pretty fun
it's a little bit like of a challenge
but nothing too like
hard to learn at all and it's really
funny come here
baby now i'm like
our babies collecting them where where's
the little look where are they at
it gets addicting searching for them
after a while
[Music]
what is your opinion on google stadia
today
i did not get to watch anything about it
yet
today because i was setting up for the
stream
um but when i first heard about it i
thought it was
pretty awesome concept idea but i'm just
curious to see
how it's to be um you know
in effect right because i heard there
were some major
like lag issues
so i was kind of curious how that was
going to be different once it actually
came out
i did hear they were already working on
those issues like right from the start
though so
i'm like not too worried about it but
i'm going to definitely check it out
more
after this i'm excited for it i also
know that
you know with all things that are live
streaming who are you guys
that um you know there's always going to
be issues
whoa they have guns you like dying he's
like her
we always gotta say something right
before they go oh you got two
two health points left all right
that guy sounds like morty from rick and
morty yep
uh the co-creators of this game are also
the co-creators of rick and morty
created this game so that is definitely
going to be the themes that you
see i want to get this one
i like there's one guy who's just like
i'm going to kill you and i'm like
bean baby all right i guess i should go
get this guy
i um i know justin roiland helped with
this i don't know if dan harmon did
but they're er justin roland has a kind
of almost feel bad for these guys he has
a company called squanch games
he used to be called squat squatch
squanch tendo
but you know i like squash games that
sounds a little more
it sounds like something you won't get
sued for yeah whoa what is
that whoa epic
a little hover yeah yeah it's useful if
you hold down the jump
then he'll hover let's try it here i
don't know if it'll work but
i'm like so well you can use those
bouncy things up there to bounce over
this
i'm so i'm just so no i want to do it
no i'm gonna do it over here all right
let's see because they put it
where you're like pixels away from
making the jump and you're like i can
make this
[Music]
but um what
else oh yeah so the cool thing about
this game in my opinion is you know
they're very aware
of like you know the era of dlc and
stuff like that
but they made it clear that they want to
provide the dlc for free
but in like but because of that you know
it'll be
this actual game will be like full price
for longer but the dlc is going to be
free
so that's that's a pretty cool
compromise in my opinion
um and if you want to sign up for that
dlc go to squanchgames.com
[Laughter]
get out mr baba's house for me
i will see you
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah totally dlc free dlc yeah free dlc
before mr pop-up rudely interrupted us
god what's his name i don't even
remember his name i only remember
michael yeah that's the guy we're
supposed to
supposedly supposed to burn his house
dude i'm just like
curious to see if maybe there's like a
audio setting in the
menu or something we could check i don't
even know where i am i can't
i nailed it boom
give me give me a little power baby um
but yeah so go to squanchgames.com
join dash list
and then sign up when the dlc goes live
they'll email you and then you get to
check out awesome
dlc turn up the game a little okay will
do
oh i killed him plus the music is
fantastic
yeah the music is awesome it's it's a
bit the game is a bit iffy because
when you hear the audio i have to kind
of like turn
the controller so that we hear it from
like our left or right here
but it's yeah it's odd so we're gonna
have to adjust the audio like
you know when you guys can't hear it let
us know and then
we'll figure it out it just seems like
it's a little off axis
which is strange like when i was playing
it on my own area
this is where residential houses are
allowed to be and michael's house
you're going to destroy it otherwise you
won't get
this the crystal of it anyways
[__] [__] [__] you i'm going inside
and that guy's an [__]
does this game actually look good to you
i actually like it
because it's not going for anything
specific
they've created their own world
well being baby though
i'm too old for this [__] okay i see
what we have to do i think
i like it i think because i'm very
bad with like where i'm going
like perception wise it's like depth
perception
i've been using like the little circle
under him to kind of help me with like
oh i killed him oh yeah you said r3 is
gonna be more useful yeah that's true
you're right you're right sorry trophy
got it okay okay interact with this
thing
[Music]
yeah we're gonna stop
don't use your slam attack yes so
basically if you
attack while you're in there
[Music]
and they interact with like everything
you do as you do it too
which is really funny like later on when
you move blocks and stuff
the two enemies they're like standing on
a tower and they're like oh look at this
guy moving his blocks oh you're so cool
and she's like they were watching me oh
[__] that worked
good good job whoa
tony i moved my stand up here because
they kept raising the property tax down
there
really high numbers up here it's really
low so the property tax situation is
pretty darn good so that's why i moved
up here i hope you guys are having a
good old saturday
[Music]
if he would have killed his pet he'd
come up here and he'd still be crying
and he'd be like
[__] you guys kill my pets like he's
still like super distraught it's so
funny
cyborg man says why is there a
controller on the screen so you
the player are a chair orpian and the
chair europeans they don't leave their
chairs their chairs float around
and they use these controllers to move
their chair
you're going to be able to defeat
glorcon's minions
and
oh [__] he's coming over here like right
when you're trying to like go through
when they're trying to do a little
dialogue all right come on bud
1v1 me 1v1 me bro
i can hurt you get out of here
get out of here i don't want to i have
to go destroy someone's
yeah i think house killed the head guy
like early
so these are like just the goons
i'm just like jumping up and down
yes this is indeed a vr game we are just
using the
the controller for the stream today yeah
oh shoot i missed fine we're good get
out of here
the cliff saved you yeah
clones after us like that all right well
we're basically at
michael's house okay let's go bean baby
baby bean baby
yeah like you know they're gonna be
floating around somewhere well the area
is just too big that there
has to be a baby another green power
baby green baby
baby it's so funny the way he talks
because i feel like i've caught myself
just like
talking like that also just like in day
to day life be like oh man
that's so [__] cool and this is like
oh man
my christmas hey michael come out yeah
michael come out here
here michael
oh what you want man this is a private
event
i don't give a [__] we're here to put
your house over the cliff
oh oh oh you're pushing this house over
this one right here
yeah give me one
out of here get the hell off my property
are you kidding me i will ruin your
house
everything mr pop-up crystal of ithace
[__] that guy's just pissed cause i hate
his family wait seriously
that's right but what papa needs to
realize is that we're all
just meat their energy is still around i
just ate their meat
okay energy never dies the flesh
can be consumed but this spiritual
energy is still in the cosmos you
[__] [__]
you want dates i'll give you my
christopher's right here if you knock
that boulder over the cliff onto mr
pop-up's house
and kill him if you'll excuse me i'm
gonna go back inside where i have a
whole mess of pregnant ladies
strapped onto the floor where i'm using
an intricate network of fluids
to inject into their bodies and induce
early birth so that i can consume the
flesh of their fetuses
okay is that okay
no not really actually that's kind of
one of these types turn me facing you so
we can talk for a second
already turn but hey bud come here we
need to have a conversation here walk me
over to you
i'm here all right listen i wasn't even
supposed to be here what do you want to
do do you want to kill mr papaya i was
doing that too i'm going to kill
somebody nice if i make him pace because
i want to get the stupid chart a bit the
police and get out of here
okay so what do you what are you what
are you thinking you you want to kill mr
pop-up
okay so now you make a choice you want
to go pop up or you want to kill michael
my partner like we did with the old man
yes or no like nod your head yes
okay so michael you want to kill michael
okay yeah
i mean the guy this guy michael's
talking about injecting fluids
into pregnant women and inducing
pregnancy and eating
their babies i mean i i see where you're
coming from okay so
you want to kill michael then yeah and
when they start asking you multiple
times then i'm like
we reached into his ball of [__] and
house
it in your face i mean for god's sakes
uh
final answer jay the one's like what the
whole kind of effort
exactly and it's not even it's because
you're true
poop on me right like listen i get it
you live your life you do what you need
to do
innocent pregnant women right off the
cliff here we go
[Laughter]
right when he says that it's like wait
you're right
how do i knock you out so you attack it
so yeah dude what the hell knocked it
off
seriously stop peace out
he's like you're gonna kill all these
innocent pregnant and
hey oh my god you guys did it you
god no you guys actually did it i
thought you guys would have just picked
one of those crystals up off the ground
it seemed like the most logical way to
do nothing oh
what are you talking about you did it i
didn't know i didn't think you would
have had what it takes
i'm not gonna lie i'm really sad that
michael's gone
but i've got bigger issues ahead of me i
need to find out where all my pregnant
wives are
here's your crystal of ithacas
[Music]
[Laughter]
that'll warp me back to the telepod you
came in get the [__] out of my world
you limped leg chair [__] stupid
sucking head i missed their pop-up
oh god is he going back to his house
okay tell you you know you surprised me
back there chair orpian i didn't think
you had what it takes to kill somebody
and then he makes
you want all the power babies because i
can give you the low down where all
those bad boys are right now
oh you want to go and also finish him
off oh oh yeah
nice just get him both screw that guy
how do i get it i'll jump on the eye
that's right that's right the bouncy eye
i don't know if it's going to work
[Music]
i killed pop-up in my play-through it
only took
one hit of the rock oh dang it
because i would i hate him too
well everyone knows i will kill i want
to kill both of them
and i killed michael and i guess
a lot of pregnant women yeah whoops
what's even more hilarious is like all
those pregnant women were
pop-ups wives oh yeah like dang what
about
leia oh no no no no no
wait wait just hold on jay the one says
the full nonsense of this game is making
me want it even more
right that is what i'm saying the more i
played it the more i was like it's so
insane and crazy that's
yeah i also like that you get to decide
a couple things and
you get like responses for like what you
do
yeah this game is awesome in vr
says zack attacks games
oh and just for the record i went back i
restarted my whole game and went back to
this
just to see if there were crystals the
first time because i was like there's no
way i didn't see that no there's not
you don't have to use vr but i hear that
is the best way to play this game so
yeah i think
with vr you can hear like the audio
better you don't have to like turn your
head and
do things but that doesn't mean this
isn't that bad please enter the telepod
cool all right listen we're back in the
telepod and the first order of business
is let's store some of those green power
babies all right yeah
just rotate around until you see the
smack that button
so they all go in there and then as you
collect them it raises your
overall health oh great only 10.
oh my god i'm gonna now i can take more
damage
see that's what happens when you collect
these green power babies all right
okay we're really rocking and rolling
we had a few more he had a few more yeah
but that doesn't mean anything
you're doing good on the green power
baby but there's still a lot more to go
see if we could go out and get the rest
of the power babies that you left out
there
i mean you can i think you can go back
out uh do we want no we should continue
yeah for
story's sake we'll continue although
it's very fun finding all of us
good work you got the crystal and it
looks like trovers already installed it
and upgraded the telepod
now you just have to teleport to the
abstainers home world
inner sanctum very rare opportunity for
anyone good work guys for anyone sure
totally cheesy and i gotta admit
i never saw you i never thought you had
it in you to cold-bloodedly murder
somebody like that
yeah that's true i didn't even rubs it
in like
you're pretty good out here in this
cosmos you know yep you're gonna party
pretty good
zack says great all the way through and
enjoy i do i do
love the fact that they remind me now
i'm a cold-blooded killer yeah
yeah yeah i did i'm sorry i got to say
that
because i almost killed the other guy
too this is
giant foggy void must be nice
all right so let's go talk to the
abstainers
their inner sanctum yeah i'm telling you
the music on all the stages
now i'm gonna turn up the volume so we
can hear this music
[Music]
okay sorry i had to enjoy
enjoy them hasn't even dropped i know
the beat didn't drop yet
[Music]
all right they're like so far
yes welcome it's true the dogs were
yours
the bond you have is strong yep
we see all we know
all but we can no longer be sure
of the future slow talker now that
gloricon is broke free
he was one of us we were four and total
yeah
i mean it's a bunch of [__] really
if you think about it he [__] us
yeah now we're three right we abstain
from interference
group project anything yeah because we
don't [__] with [__]
yeah yeah and we're the abstainers and
we abstain from stuff
they said a bunch of bad stuff is coming
oh oh geez oh my god oh
dumb dub bad stuff
i'm gonna start saying that whenever
something doesn't go my way proceeding
with his plan to destroy the universe
the cosmos everything
what what destroy the whole that's right
you little purple
hunk and you two together are our only
hope oh boy you must
collect glorcon the clones you must
collect their guts
we will be able to use that we got it
so we're able to see what his next moves
are it's the only way we can stop
the horrible things from happening what
are you talking about us i don't i don't
want to i i don't want to deal with this
get the [__] out of here hurry get the
[__] out of here
hurry get the [__] out of here hurry get
up get out
get out i like how they're like you're
our only hope now get out
get get go yeah give us
no nothing no details nothing they're
just like
you got it you got it you two are doing
it
shut up get out of here leave okay cool
[Music]
put this on a record player please i
know
i will buy the entire soundtrack to this
game right now soundtrack's awesome
[Music]
hello what's going on hey hey
here the stakes have been raised galore
khan's trying to destroy the whole
universe
and the obsceners want us to stop him
hold on trover
shut the [__] up let me talk to the
chair here jerorphian is it true if the
stakes been raised
uh yes they have they'll be fine okay
so what you say is true drove her yeah
mistakes have been raised
according to the chair european trover
what are you going to do you're going to
[__] sit on your little pansy ass
while the whole cosmos gets blown up and
destroyed
are you going to [__] pony up you and
the chair orpian are the only hope
the abstainer said it to me earlier
bitching and
need you to fill up the glorcon clone
guts into the cauldron and come back to
the telepod all right
get the [__] out of here i'm gonna go
shoot some hoops sick
i like planet shroomia all right shrimp
shroomies man i thought we would be
wrapping it up back there you know
this is turning out to be a way bigger
deal than i thought it would be
listen i'm a whole monster you're a
jorpian we're not meant to be a team
but we're partners now you hear that i
acquiesce
we're partners i don't want to be
together with you but we are
and we're in way over our heads so you
know just don't stress
you should have went back because they
were talking about something weird and
it's true right here we are
here in chicago when you start running
away they're like oh yeah
now i can take off my pants they're
leaving i need to air out my thing
i'm like oh my god and if you run back
over there they go oh i thought you were
leaving why did you come back
so it's so awesome the way they interact
with you that's great
all right i was too focused on getting
keep your eyes cute
i'm the one that's just like okay i
heard my mission i gotta go
yeah ranch style home with a two-car
garage
[Music]
which sounds like something that
probably wouldn't exist in this world
but no it literally is like one story
home
two two car garage yeah no chairs cause
he'll never wanna remember me
[Music]
doopy dooper
so doopy dooper is mad annoying which is
that
um you're about to meet i don't know if
it's a
boy or a girl it's like it sounds like a
girl but i think
like oh no way that was a tv show he was
watching okay
i was like no not another one of those
yeah what do you guys think
over here what a good guy i think it's a
girl
um how do i get up here how can i get up
here
oh you'll have to wait until uh you
unlock a new ability
oh okay okay yeah got it got it
look what fury says i honestly don't
know what i'm seeing looks like it came
for stoners
and started like it's an lsd trip it's
so funny too because
whenever they talk about the power
babies trover's always like man i get
super high off these things
we got ourselves a little purple apple
monster
these guys are so annoying oh
look at this little character popping up
popping up getting in our face get out
of here
doopy doopers please like you guys
talking about get the [__] out of here
do you see a house in there
all right okay so you don't see his
house okay yeah that's right there's
nobody [__] lives in here this is our
super cool glorcon this way fortress
is the coolest clerk on fortress ever i
will see this i will destroy your house
oh yeah no the time is coming
oh hi easy easy partner you know
you better make sure every one of these
jumps that you think about it
and and you time it just right because
i'm not i don't want to follow
this muck and when i say muck i'm
referring to the ground up
yeah it's like dead power babies it's
gross it smells bad
power babies awkward yeah power baby
slime okay
[Music]
you're like so close you still miss
these goons
oh sweet oh power baby grip power baby
i'm sure the voice actors had a lot of
fun making this power baby i hope it was
worth it to you probably the one get me
slimy right
go ahead and say that that was the right
call good work partner thank you keep
going we gotta we gotta move
okay cool let's go let's go let's go
partner come on let's go
i also don't trust trover i
figure
[Laughter]
[Music]
smash attack
eventually you learn how to roll and
then it's like super easy to
beat everybody yeah oh that's cool okay
let's keep going there's a house here
[Music]
yeah
okay so we do have a puzzle coming up
it's pretty easy
it's not hard hey hey are you are you
doopy dooper
yeah yeah i'm doopy
our boss sent us here because you're
supposed to have some sort of magic
cauldron
vessel thing you mean that bowl thing
yeah i know that's long gone those
chicken nugget characters
they [__] it up in their kitchen
damn it yeah the only way to get into
that fort is up on that cliff there
just up there past my house do you see
it
yeah that one right there yeah yeah
that's it
and the only way you can get up to that
cliff is if i reveal the secret
staircase
okay yeah so can you turn on the secret
staircase oh yeah
sure i'll reveal it that seems kind of
cool
do you know how to pick stuff up and
move it
uh no i haven't done it so
really well that's all right thank you i
got this chair
you can use to help pick stuff up okay
and uh all right
now you can be so upset like my tv
great yes zippy aj
[Music]
left or right on the d-pad there you go
perfect right there
now i can watch my shows pray your
eddies
now i just need you to move those boxes
over to that house
right there the one with the basketball
okay great yeah now just set it anywhere
in front of the house
right over there come first in front of
the house do you not know what a house
is
i heard her give us a second
there perfect right there is perfect
and moving stuff to someone's house
we're helping helping doopy move
it's like it's just like not even
you made me do this you know i've had a
tough time lately
i'm trapped in this mechanical chair in
it
sorry
[Laughter]
i changed my mind can you move the boxes
in the garage
i checked the weather and it said it
could rain no boy
marco this game is not vr only we're
actually playing with control right now
but
i have heard many many times and the vr
version is the best so
you have options but i don't recommend
being honest i'll open the staircase
we're helping do people listen we're in
a lot of trouble here okay we can't [__]
around with this [__]
i got it i got it uh
[Music]
wanted you guys to hold off on doing
that i just checked the weather
and it looks like it's all cleared up
plus ouch
oh no jeez
oh you got me oh that was a hard one
what come on this is [__] we had a
deal
and reveal the staircase please stop
yelling at me you're scaring me
no you don't need the vr to play this
which is a good thing oh my god
this this is it then no more after this
we do this and then we get the secret
staircase no more
i promise i never break my promise
so now doopy wants you to put the boxes
on the roof
oh god
oh she wants you to move him outside
first and then she wants you to put him
on the roof
i was just like all right
she took a couple hits like a champ
compared to that their boxes are outside
[__] sake reveal the secret staircase
okay no need for foul language here
i will reveal the secret staircase but
not
until one last thing i want you
to put the boxes on my roof
all right i'm already doing it so now
let the fun begin
so i have to like figure out how to put
them there so they don't fall right
over
what else can i use these boxes for
realize how crazy this [__] was
just earlier the whole universe is at
stake
screw this actually should i use them to
get that
i don't know screw it i'm done with this
place
screw your beam when you're doing your
100 run
then yeah [__] are you thinking what i'm
thinking partner
i know don't explain staircase
trying to like get this right get it to
actually be a stair like
i'll move my back shut up deal's off
[__]
yeah yeah see trevor catches on he's
like oh yeah this is smart
deal's off all right i think that's
i think he can jump onto this person
let's go tropher is this on switch not
that i know of
it is not we did it yes
and then she's just over there talking
trash this is crisis the
little doopy dooper's a lunatic
damn partner that
you got us out there quick you must hate
people in wheelchairs
of course that must be what that means
freaking trover
i was actually willing to help her yeah
i was like sure do you want me to do
what
even if it's just a couple of things and
then they offered him
and then i realized no you can actually
go this the round that route
all right you got a green filler baby
yeah
[Music]
all right let's keep going troves
um all right so now i remember seeing
those little platforms in the beginning
of the stage
now that we have this cool new ability
we can actually
move it oh that pink one right there
he's standing to this right
it's like an elevator there you go
lady
[Music]
surprise shitbags i'm killing you myself
to you i'm killing you myself all by
myself yes sure
yeah totally that worked out very well
[Music]
i don't even notice me getting hit until
i look down
can we please play the whole game on
stream i
wish dude it would be awesome however we
do have about
15 minutes left of the stream for today
but um yeah i would definitely recommend
you guys trying out this game if you
want to if you don't have vr on your
ps4 that's totally fine you can use
controller um it's also now out on pc
and there's going to be free dlc on the
way if you guys want to sign up for that
dlc
just go to squanchgames.com join
dash list yeah our join hyphen
list everything she has said
i am there with it i can't go that
i can't um you can't but if you put the
block on top of the platform
trove or get off totally again
no no
screw this i'm going to keep going story
i'm not 100
right now those idiots
man we were having a good conversation
oh man we're having a conversation oh no
you got two health points left
that's okay you just got a red power
baby from smacking up that fool
one more
i'm coming after your [__] ass
this is like what i would expect people
to really say if they're in this
situation
he was shaking his butt at you there's
like those guys
[Music]
they probably would damage each other if
you got them into that situation
[__] their face
[Music]
i feel like these guys talk like every
kid on xbox live back in 2005
[Music]
oh the matrix judging all the bullets
call me
[Music]
you know i'm sick and tired of these
puzzles you know this this isn't what
this isn't what it's supposed to be
about you know
yep yep me too actually
i think if you put it just near the hole
don't forget you can pop up it's going
to make it's easier it makes things
easier
no i like things difficult
i like making my life difficult okay if
i just
like that that's oh hey look at you
solving this puzzle huh
look at you solving this puzzle
how come it doesn't pull up you might
have to pop up
no this world just seems like a bunch of
puzzles like some kind of
puzzle person that's a bunch of houses
what's up so chilled welcome to this
just
with a bunch of puzzles i mean this must
be a lawyer's
uh what dream this place this is where
lawyers are squirting
okay creep on this guy right yeah
again yeah put it in that top of the
circle
you got to hop up that wall so i put it
in the wrong area
i'm gonna get what you're doing but hey
shut up trevor i'm not a puzzle guy
i'm not about puzzles
i believe in you i don't
or are you are you working on figuring
this thing out
yeah are you working on figuring
figuring this thing out trover do you
not see what we're doing right now
so there's no way to rotate it like
straight straight on good question
usually when i pick them up like from
being flat it was like so like they were
already flat so
i didn't know too much yet okay
oh you can pull it closer to yourself if
you need space to rotate it
and rotate there we go
there we go get it in the hole
rotated it for me cool that should work
right
does that work perfect god
puzzles you might have to put that
second one in the right side hole
really but we'll see if we can make it
up there because when i did this one
he landed inside the cubby on the right
is it because it's higher
i think because there's a space in that
top cubby for him to land in between the
block
and then jump onto the block okay
i thought i had it all right
there we go come on let's get out let's
get out of here
[Music]
this that's the one thing i don't like
about this game but i think it's just me
is that i don't have the proper
perception to figure it out
but i might be just done
oh i keep jumping over it
okay okay
all right one okay
[Music]
i believe i don't
there we go boom easy peasy shop trophy
shop traveler shout out
shout out to our tour okay
so um
uh so i got an overflow
oh i also got a power baby upgrade
huh how much for the power baby upgrade
interested in the power
baby huh i like the cut of your jib
don't tell you what sir i'll make you a
deal my pet mushroom character
is over there in the middle of all those
mushroom monsters if you go
rescue him i will give you this roll
upgrade
how do we know which one is your pet i
mean they all look the same
hey don't give me that don't don't you
give me that nonsense you know the
difference
between a pet and a monster come on oh
boy
[Music]
they're all attacking me yeah i know
they all look pretty angry
i'm gonna just kill them all if you just
don't tell me
i feel like it's a trap well i'm killing
them you just killed my best scrabby you
[__] who the hell is the matter with you
well you should've told me i didn't know
that was your path they
between a pet and a monster just take
the power baby upgrade you're lucky i
need room for scrappy's babies that's
right
you just made a dozen babies into
orphans i hope you're [__] happy
listen i killed a bunch of pregnant
women i know right we're on a roll to
this point i'm a
monster
[Music]
for me another step up the old ladder
this never gets old i got to tell you
these little
power baby upgrades it's it's it's a
little bonus
jonas for me through my veins
button then you ugh roll your ass out of
my life forever
cool cool sounds good
so can you damn
oh there's a little wall here you can
roll under
oh here okay i was just thinking could
you do
a roll and then jump further
[Music]
to the glorcon clones fort
star dude says he wants to become a vr
game developer okay so if you do
can we please make a ghost hunting vr
you're gonna come and send them that'd
be
[Music]
watch cool not on my watch this is what
you get when you trust trover you'll
become a monster
for sure those jerks we kept them out
i'm sure this isn't gonna be completely
annoying with them watching us
[Music]
you know what don't talk so loud you
don't
don't talk too loud a little
it's like you just have to listen to
them
they don't know how to fight nothing
look at them
all right cool the goons are down i'm
gonna heckle you all day long because
you're
stupid dummies you're not gonna get into
this
what are you trying to get what are you
trying to get all clothes
for
is going to help you get in here i don't
think so oh
look at you with the big look at you
with the big blocks
man those guys are driving me crazy
i don't think you can kill them with it
but
i don't think dang it there's nothing
you can do to stop the club
oh man that would be cool if you could
just slide them off and then beat them
up dang it
yeah you can't hit them
[Music]
[Laughter]
you guys are gonna regret [__] talking
us when when we
right partner look let's just figure out
a way to get in there it shouldn't be
too hard
[Music]
no what what what what message she said
that we gotta kill
that little trover guy a little purple
guy in the chair
should i go this way yeah yeah we got
ourselves
a round pretty much all right
now there's some more i mean uh i think
there's one like on that list
i know we gotta do it
where oh okay
[Music]
yeah you start unlocking like so many
different things you can do you're like
oh yeah i have that privilege now
oh gosh and
surprise here's gonna be a power baby
under that block
oh don't throw it off somebody got it
throw it off the map don't tell it
got it a hundred percent
[Music]
that was the last one i found on the
stage after i searched for like 20
minutes i was like where
is he because i used three other blocks
and i didn't use that
you have enough uh jumping power too you
just have to get closer
i'm wearing that flush with my body so
you can't as long as i need three
shut the [__] up
[Laughter]
he's like my spirit and while he like
had his hand on his forehead and
everything he's like god they just woke
up
just a husk there's no life left in this
body you know actually i think that
might be two we're gonna have to do that
right that's a tough call
we gotta kill these two you know that's
our whole point there are
enemies
god damn those [__] keep just
[__] talking
yeah anyway listen uh i'm trying to tell
you
[Music]
and then they're like super easy
that was good yeah cool
now the gates open and then this is like
the boss fights
of this stage all right partner although
it's 12 30 i feel like
they're like so cute too they kind of
remind me have you ever seen
um this movie called cj7 no i have not
it's like a movie it's like a son of a
[__] who's hiding pretty good
and there's this little alien she's
called cj7 that like
comes down and this little boy he's
really poor but he finds him but
his body looks like the power baby's
body but he has like a furry face it's
really cute
all right here we go yeah there's a lot
of power babies in here
so when you kill the guys next to this
cauldron
it like sucks out their goods so you're
trying to fill this this
pot this cauldron okay so they're good
that's close yeah
you can also pick up the pot and move it
if you need to if it's not like close
enough to them
if you know what i mean i don't holy
[__] there's a bunch of reruns of golden
girls on right now out here
he's like i'm gonna draw them out hey
there's gold i'm coming i heard it i
heard it i'm coming
hey wait a minute you son of a [__] i'm
getting them
i've found myself popping up to like the
highest state every time i walk into an
area
i don't know why i guess like the eagle
eye view is just like easier for me
you can move the cauldron over to them
[Music]
yeah okay now beat him up
he ran into the pipe and he fell down
come on guys
and i'll kill the clones oh
[Music]
it looks far now or maybe zoom in
it just like moved accidentally let's
move it
over here
i don't think that's a good idea
actually maybe i should and it's fine
we'll just
slice and dice them really quick yeah
boom whoops
all right nice we gotta get the other
goons out here now
so many babies
they're like evil henchmen but they're
like guys did you hear the kid fell on
the wall yeah
let's go help them
it's within range troops all right relax
[Music]
aye
protect the culture and kinda i mean
it's super durable
i know right it's already taken a couple
hits
he's over there dodging nothing
there he goes come to us
come to us baby
little baby no come back
he's like floating
just having a grand old time while
trevor's over here
yeah doing work fighting off these
chicken nuggets come here guys
i guess i should they won't move i know
that yeah they're camping
so this is a boss like their version of
a boss battle um well this is the lead
up to the
to the boss so he's about the final
guy's about to come out pretty soon man
i really wish there was somebody else
here that could help me finish eating
this
um candy out from the state fan
the apple from the state food get out of
my way
now we know the things that you know the
goons like they're like golden girls
they like saving kids from water
i'm gonna [__] kill you [__] you a
punk
[Music]
can they hurt each other do you know
that um i think so
i think so
[Music]
okay get out of here
holy crap we're killing it partner we're
[__] a good team
holy [__] yeah we're ready fantastic i'm
the shield glorcon clone
okay now boss battle that's okay we got
power baby
i got power baby though okay so he has
armor
so obviously you can't hit him straight
on so
as any boss battle has there's going to
be moments where you can get to him and
he's vulnerable
yeah okay right there like right there
bing bang boom
he's gotta bait him you're a [__]
dummy if he hits the cauldron though
that thing goes flying like across the
whole stage
nice the hat is off
okay so i have to be kind of near him
yeah
and i think you can slam attack him like
jump over him and then
slam attack him and then he'll like dive
for you and then
slice them up
oh yeah there you go don't forget we
need to go oh my gosh
yeah there's two now you're really
[__]
yeah right we've got plot armor bro
[Music]
okay um we're playing this without vr
just for the stream's sake and you know
because we're hanging out also so we
want to be able to
both interact with each other as well
but yeah 100
would recommend play this with the vr
experience
um the node movement that's pretty
popular like you know
like movement option in vr so you can
tell it's definitely designed
for the vr experience yeah so yeah
the audio too you can hear
okay um baited with punish again
let's go oh no patience oh
we got footsies and one more time
in the money yeah yeah yeah he's dead
easy
[Music]
pick that thing up let's go let's get
out of here partner
oh okay cool cool so i'm back
to the pod in which
we've completed this track well almost
completed we're gonna run into
doopy again
doopy and her doopiness
hey hello oh great it's you again
yeah i stole that locking technology
from one of those chicken nuggets and i
locked the snow
down yeah you did that i could say i'm
sorry
i want to make amends with you enough oh
god i really need a favor
can i push her off i want you to move me
back to my
original house if you have a sack uh i
wanted to live in that house with the
basketball hoop but
over time that basketball hoop came to
haunt me
it's always good oh
you can push
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't hit me i'm for real this time i'm
gonna actually die if you knock me off
this cliff
i stop it i have the power baby in my
possession
okay
[Music]
let's go can we not get out now that
she's dead
oh okay i was about to say that would be
really serious
game over all right boom we've made it
we've made it we've did two chapters um
yeah obviously you guys there's a bunch
of different ways
yeah a bunch of different ways to play
they let you make decisions
they let you like you could have helped
do be right there and then she gives you
a power baby
you know to collect um or you could just
knock her off a cliff right and like
that's the fun of the whole game is that
you get to make these cool decisions
i've killed a lot of people
no i love your play through actually
because like
for me when i was thinking i was like oh
man i would love to kill tb right now
but i want that power baby so i just
went and did her like deed anyways but
no
your playthrough was like everything i
wanted to see
i'm assuming you can't get the power
baby anymore and like do 100
now yeah yeah well i mean
oh well it's all good darn trover saves
the universe vr experience we didn't
play it in vr but i would recommend to
go check it out in vr
it's really fun yes it is now available
on
pc and ps4 so check that out free dlc on
the way go to squanchgames.com to sign
up for that
and of course thank you guys for tuning
in and
lily thank you thank you this has been
fun yes this week was awesome and i'm
definitely gonna be
dragging lily onto the show more so um
yeah
look forward to that and e3 with game
three omg e3
is gonna be amazing e3 is coming up next
week and um if anybody is in the area
we are going to have a game spot base
station outside as well as our booth
inside but if you don't have a pass to
get inside
you can come to the base station without
a badge
and have fun and meet some of the
awesome talent we have scheduled play
some games
i'm going to be cosplaying as honeydew
may on tuesday so please come through
and check it out
um because i'm really excited and i've
been to e3 before but this is my first
time like
going as like entry like with a company
so i'm like
super excited awesome you're gonna do
great yay all right guys thanks so much
for tuning in and of course we are here
monday through friday at 11 a.m so
come on back next time you're here bye
you